ous souvenez-vous de cette vidéo
que j'avais fait il y a 3 ans qui s'appelait
"QUAND J'ETAIS PETIT ET INNOCENT!"
C'était une vidéo dans laquelle je regardais
Les photos de moi plus jeune quand j'avais entre 6 et 12 ans.
D'ailleurs c'est très drôle parce que maintenant si tu regarde cette vidéo
Tu te rends compte qu'elle au moment ou j'avais fait cette vidéo j'étais petit en fait
"Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie"
Pour x raisons j'ai récemment demandé à mon père de repartager le dossier qui contenait toutes ces photos
et je me suis aperçu que dedans il y avait des vidéos ! (#Jesuisaveugle)
que je n'avait pas vues à l'époque, je crois qu'elles étaient pas dans le dossier en vrai à l'époque
Des vidéos de moi quand j'avais 7 ans ou 8 ans
avec mon énorme tête à claque et la même coupe de cheveux que maintenant d'ailleurs
Bien évidemment mon frère va aussi prendre cher car il est forcément dans ces vidéos
Florent Hauchard je m'excuse je suis vraiment désolé (*Rire sournois*)
Bon la dernière fois tu m'as démonté sur tekken là c'est ma petite vengeance OK?!
Ok première vidéo c'est parti !
*Bruit de fond*
ça fait un peu PEDOBEAR ce début de vidéo *Rire*
ça fait un peu un mec qui regarde un enfants de 8 nager en slip de bain ( MAIS OUI C'EST SA )
C'est très bizzare #Voixvirile
Bon la deuxième, elle sera peut être mieux, j'espère.
*Bruit de fond* + DAMMIT
Putain mais ce Skill déjà à l'époque c'est incroyable
Musique épique + Montage épique
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOPE
mec je devais vraiment être le pire gamin pour ça
je pense que aucun autre gamin n'a fait autant de fois peur à ses parents
en faisant des cascades dégueulasses
3 ans de gymnastique hein je vous rappelle hein
donc forcément après on développe des petits skills
on est un peu agile hein
OK ensuite, AH, situation différente
oula qu'est ce que c'est que ça
ohh putain c'est Florent Hauchard ça
AAhhh j'ai hâte de voir sa tête !
ahhhh il aurait préféré que je gagne à Tekken et éviter ce supplice
hein Florent ?
avec ma belle-mère
*bruit qui provoque un malaise*
c'est quoi le problème hein ?
*vieux rire de Squeezie des familles*
eh mais Florent, eh mon frère c'était un petit caïd en vrai putain
j'me souvenais pas mec
"c'est quoi le problème hein ?"
*musique thuuug*
on a eu la même voix quand je muais
c'est très amusant
bon suivant !
3, 2, 1, ça tourne !
c'est la voix de mon frère les amis
c'est la voix de ce mec là
"on va faire une valeur sûre : gros seins, c'est un très large choix de personnages"
c'est bizarre parce que quand j'avais son âge je parlais exactement de cette manière là aussi
c'est hyper étrange
coupez ! c'est quoi ça ?
bon aller hop ça tourne
*rire* mon père ça lui casse les couilles
à la votre hein, bon ben on fait "tchin", *tchin*
on dirait moi c'est trop bizarre !
est ce que je vais arriver sur la vidéo c'est ça que je me demande
ça serait tellement drôle
"la dégustation se fait, pour tout spécimen"
*rires*
"cet énergumène par exemple, à mangé un bout de taureau sauvage"
mec j'ai envie de me gifler
mais mec j'avais vraiment la pire tête à claque de France
c'est un truc de malade j'ai envie de me mettre des claques
et de me couper la mèche
bon remise en contexte : c'était en vacances, avec mon père et ma belle-mère
j'avais 8 ans je crois un truc comme ça
et j'étais la plus grande tête à claque de France
hein on va pas se mentir
j'appréciais comme maintenant les bonnes choses
à savoir la charcuterie, le bon saucisson des familles au soleil on connaît bien
mais mec, il reste 1min de vidéo, là, mon âme est en train de mourir dans cette vidéo vraiment
"regardez comme il agresse sa pauvre petite proie, inoffensive et sans défense"
"heureusement qu'il ne m'a pas encore vu, je suis tapi dans les buissons"
"eh j'te rappelle t'es pas dans les buissons là t'es juste devant nous"
WAOUW merci Lucas Hauchard pour cette intervention d'enfant de 8 ans incroyable !
"ah ouais"
qu'est ce qu'on vient de voir, qu'est ce qu'on vient de voir ?
je vais lui envoyer en photo
la dernière fois déjà je lui avait envoyé une photo dossier
ah elle est incroyable *rires*
en fait depuis qu'il m'a battu à Tekken 1000 fois en vidéo j'ai grave la haine
et la dernière fois je lui avais envoyé celle photo là pour me venger
waw quel homme !
papa, j'aurais pas dit mieux, franchement j'aurais pas dit mieux
la tête que tu fais là, je me retiens de la faire depuis le début de la vidéo
suivant !
AHHHHHH alors ça, alors ça je m'en souviens très très bien
vu que j'ai mes parents divorcés, je faisais 1 année sur 2 Noel chez ma mère et 1 année sur 2 Noel chez mon père
enfin le soir de noel, en vrai je le faisais chaque année avec mes 2 parents
mais avec l'un c'était le vrai soir de Noël et avec l'autre c'était le lendemain
et cette année là, (claude françois) c'était chez mon père
et mon père, mine de rien quand on était petits on jouait énormément aux jeux vidéos avec lui
à mario kart et aussi à mario kart, et à mario kart aussi
et ils avaient une PS2 et il avait acheté la playstation eyetoy je crois elle s'appelait
c'était les prémises de la kinect si vous voulez
ou euh c'était les premiers jeux il me semble où tu pouvais bouger dans l'espace
et ça détectait  dans le jeu, et du coup c'était des jeux de courses
où fallait sauter, où fallait courrir, fallait crier c'était rigolo
c'était un peu comme la wii au final, mais en moins bien foutu
et donc là on jouait à ce truc-là et je crois que j'étais l'enfant le plus ignoble du monde
j'arrêtais pas de crier, de gesticuler dans tous les sens
et vous allez voir que ça casse les couilles à mon frère vraiment
il a envie de me défoncer la gueule
*regarde j'suis trop petit, j'suis trop petit moi*
*mets-les plus haut*
Regardez l'installation à l'ancienne !!
c'est génial !
avec ma vieille polaire bleue mec que j'ai mis 600 milliards de fois quand j'étais plus jeune
merci maman d'avoir acheté un seul pull pour 8 années vraiment
je m'éclatais, vraiment, c'était l'un des plus beau noel de ma vie
vous l'avez vu ou pas ? est-ce que vous l'avez vu ? il était discret il était furtif
en fait vu que c'était mal foutu, la playstation eyetoy elle galérait un peu à capter
et du coup je m'approchais de la caméra pour qu'il me capte mieux
mais du coup il captait moins bien ceux qu'il y avait derrière moi
et donc mon frère il arrêtait pas de mettre son bras devant moi
comme ça et de le reculer comme vous l'avez vu
et des fois, je pense même qu'à un moment il va rager
"mais Lucas t'es sur mon truc t'es con"
AH VOILA, voilà dès le début de la 2ème vidéo c'est l'insulte qui est sortie de la part de Florent Hauchard
c'est génial mec, en fait, c'est dingue comme, dans nos souvenirs, même ma belle famille
tu oublies à l'époque qu'ils avaient cette gueule en fait
j'ai l'impression que mon frère a toujours eu la gueule qu'il a maintenant
j'me souvenais pas du tout de lui avec la voix qui mue
même ses attitudes ses manières de parler complètement différentes, c'est hyper marrant
j'avais complètement oublié tout ça
*cris de florent*
wow calme toi Florent
*cris de Lucas totalement hystérique*
mais mec je suis insupportable ohhhh putaain
je donne raison à tous ceux qui me détestent de me détester là, c'est terrible
"attends c'est n'importe quoi"
bah ouais !
mais Florent c'est pas grave si t'as perdu à la playstation eyetoy en 2002
et ouais mon pote !
Faut croire qu'à l'époque j'arrivais encore à gagner
PARDON FLORENT NE ME FRAPPE PAS
*Oh pourquoi*
Parce que t'es une grosse merde aux jeux vidéos déjà
Déjà à l'époque Lucas Hauchard
Tu fais le guide touristique mais TU PUES
Ok ok quoi d'autre
Attends c'est super marrant de voir tout ça
OH Alors ça c'est plusieurs années plus tard je devais avoir 12 ans
Et c'était en Bretagne
On était allés en Bretagne dans un mobilhome
Un putain de mobilhome minuscule infesté par les moustiques et les araignées je me souviens très bien
Et on avait fait du cerf-volant sur la plage
Donc là ça doit être une vidéo où je fais du cerf-volant sur la plage, ce qui parait logique
*Arrière bruit de vent*
*Rire*
C'est génial
Putain on dirait les vidéos drôles d'internet mais de il y a dix ans quoi t'sais
T'sais les fails à l'époque où c'était gentil
C'était juste un enfant qui est déçu devant quelque chose
T'sais il y avait pas besoin qu'un mec se péte une jambe vénère pour que ça fasse du clique
Non y'en a plusss !
Mais nonnnn y'a plus que des photos !
Regardez le trio des Hauchard à l'époque
Vous avez vu ça
Et j'me demande quelles photos j'avais montrées ou pas dans la vidéo en 2014
J'me souviens plus
Je crois pas que j'avais montré celles là
En fait à l'époque je voulais pas trop montrer des photos de mon père
Mais vu que là tfaçon vous l'avez vu dans la vidéo du Japon, jm'en fous
Et du coup ouais on revoit des p'tites photos de nos anniversaires de l'époque
Bon après tout ça on avait vu , la gymnastique
On se souvient
Les trois ans de gym ils sont là
En voici les preuves putain
Mec, la preuve, c'était deux ans ou trois ans avant la vidéo où je jouais à la PlayStation là
Regardez ce que j'ai comme pull
Regardez mon pull
N'achetez pas qu'un pull à vos enfants putain !
C'est frustrant, okay ?
Et ce qui est rigolo surtout c'est que dans ces vidéos là
On reconnaît derrière le salon de chez mon père dans lequel j'ai fais mes premières vidéos
Tout ça là, regardez bien, vous allez le reconnaître maintenant
Je crois c'était "être seul chez soi" en vrai
Qui est la pire vidéo d'internet ! N'allez surtout pas la voir c'est terrible
voilà regardez, c'est ouf
c'est ici qu'on jouait à la playstation à Noel
sauf que le point de vue c'est d'ici quoi
c'est rigolo ! Voilà petite info nulle, petite info nulle, euh voilà
bah les amis écoutez, "téléphone qui sonne" ah !
AH C'EST MON FRERE !
ouii, ça va ? "oui ça va et toi ?"
bieeen, et je faisais une vidéo où je regardais les vidéos de nous quand on était tout petit
t'sais les vidéos où on jouait à la playstation eye à Noel
tu te souviens de ça ? "ouais, mais attend on avait quel âge sur ces vidéos ?"
olala mec je sais pas mais je crois que tu me battais déjà à Taken
mais on était très jeunes, "moi il me semble que je t'ai toujours battu à Taken"
eh franchement tu baisses d'un ton direct, ce que je propose c'est de raccrocher parce que l'humiliation est trop forte
"ah bah je comprends très bien" et du coup j'ai eu ma petite vengeance
on voit ta tête quand t'as vraiment 14ans quoi, c'est très drôle
*rires de florent*
"mais attends tu vas la mettre sur le net ?
ah bien sûr bien sûr, "d'accord, donc t'as vraiment aucun respect pour ton frère"
*rires*
bon et beh les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous a plu
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à l'aimer comme d'habitude
et je trouve ça important des fois de reregarder des photos comme ça
c'est vrai que sur le moment vos parents ils prennent des photos, des vidéos
et c'est peut-être chiant sur le moment
même moi actuellement ça me fait chier quand ma mère me prend des photos
à un anniversaire ou à Noel, c'est relou
mais en vrai regardez, quand tu les revois 10 ans plus tard
ça te fais un truc
je me souvenais en plus de chacune des situations
bon en vrai ya que 3 situations mais bon je me souviens quand même des moments
mais voilà, l'idée que je me faisais de ces moments-là était finalement différente
de la réalité des choses
voilà, c'est très beau ce que je viens de dire
je vous propose de finir sur ça, moi je vais bouffer
parce qu'il est 12h08 et un corps ça s'alimente
même le mien, même si vous en doutez putain
je vous dis à bientôt les amis au revooooir
ouais quand j'ai très faim je vais comme ça à la boulangerie